Lucia:釉下彩吧
Lucia: Underglaze, I think.
Lucia:这个
Lucia: This one.
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha:釉上釉下呀
Tasha: Overglaze and underglaze.
Jake:左上左下什么意思
Jake: What do you mean by over and under?
Lucia:哈哈哈就是两种上上彩的方式
Lucia: Haha, it means two ways of applying the glaze.
Tasha: 上色工艺
Tasha: Coloring technique.
Jake:是先上什么再上什么还是什么
Jake: Is it applying one first and then the other or what?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 就相当于是你先把这个白色的烧出来
Tasha: It's like you first fire the white base.
Tasha: 然后再把这个花纹涂上去
Tasha: Then you apply the patterns.
Tasha: 还是一开始就把花纹也涂好了
Tasha: Or you apply the patterns from the start.
Jake:哦哦怎么看呢
Jake: Oh, oh, how do you tell?
Tasha: 然后再烧
Tasha: Then fire it again.
Lucia:我觉得釉上吧
Lucia: I think it's overglaze.
Tasha:嗯如果是釉上彩
Tasha: Hmm, if it's overglaze.
Tasha:如果是釉上彩的话
Tasha: If it's overglaze.
Tasha: 其实吃着就有毒
Tasha: It's actually toxic to eat.
Tasha: 就对身体不好
Tasha: It's bad for your health.
Tasha: 因为把这些矿物质原料吃进去
Tasha: Because you're ingesting these mineral materials.
Tasha:如果是釉下彩的话就更健康一点
Tasha: If it's underglaze, it's healthier.
Tasha: 但是他的花纹就没那么好看
Tasha: But the patterns aren't as pretty.
Tasha: 颜色也不好看
Tasha: And the colors aren't as nice.
Lucia:感觉回到了我大学那个课上
Lucia: Feels like I'm back in my college class.
Jake:给他们一点小任务
Jake: Give them a little task.
Jake:哎他们找到了
Jake: Oh, they found it.
Tasha: 哦都找到了
Tasha: Oh, they found it all.
Jake:哎这
Jake: Hey, this.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah?
Lucia:这给他抓回去放门口吧
Lucia: Let's grab it and leave it at the door.
Jake:啊这是谁做的
Jake: Ah, who did this?
Lucia:不是他就趴在这个帐篷里
Lucia: No, he was just lying in this tent.
Tasha: 为什么他搞了辆这么新的
Tasha: Why did he get such a new one?
Tasha:这辆这么旧
Tasha: This one is so old.
Jake:对啊为什么
Jake: Yeah, why?
Jake:从哪拿的呀
Jake: Where did he get it?
其他人：他停车场拿的
Others: From the parking lot.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:讲究
Jake: Fancy.
Choiszt: 随便拿
Choiszt: Just grabbed it.
Jake:咱不是有意思吗
Jake: Isn't it interesting?
Jake:咱们刚刚讨论过了
Jake: We just discussed this.
Nicous: 但是历史方法没拍
Nicous: But we didn't record the historical method.
Jake:二锅头整点
Jake: Get some Erguotou.
Jake:二锅头可以
Jake: Erguotou is fine.
Choiszt: 真的吗
Choiszt: Really?
Tasha: 为你点灯为你隆隆
Tasha: I'll light a candle for you, I'll bang the drum for you.
Tasha: 为你唱噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: I'll sing "deng deng deng deng deng deng deng deng deng."
Lucia:今天奇怪问答的含量好高啊
Lucia: There's a lot of strange questions today.
Lucia:啊没有刚才
Lucia: Oh, no, not just now.
Jake:对你过生日为什么去医院
Jake: Yeah, why did you go to the hospital on your birthday?
Lucia:什么情况下生日在医院上哈哈
Lucia: In what situation would you celebrate your birthday at the hospital? Haha.
Lucia:不过我有点忘记了
Lucia: But I kind of forgot.
Jake:咱就买完了
Jake: We just finished shopping.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哦茉莉花茶
Jake: Oh, jasmine tea.
Lucia:哦那是另一次
Lucia: Oh, that was another time.
Lucia:sorry我错了
Lucia: Sorry, I was wrong.
Jake:为什么4瓶啊
Jake: Why 4 bottles?
Choiszt: 哈哈因为刚才我要拿6瓶
Choiszt: Haha, because I wanted to take 6 bottles just now.
Tasha: 我们为什么要逛这里啊
Tasha: Why are we shopping here?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:讲究讲究啊行行
Jake: It's all good, it's all good.
Choiszt: 4瓶就是随便随便喝
Choiszt: 4 bottles are just for casual drinking.
Tasha: 一只手两只手能拿下的程度
Tasha: Enough for one hand or two hands to carry.
Choiszt: 对
Choiszt: Yeah.
Choiszt: 两个有点少
Choiszt: Two is a bit too few.
Jake:他这边很多夹子耶
Jake: There are a lot of clips here.
Choiszt: 什么夹子
Choiszt: What clips?
Jake:不知道是什么东西
Jake: I don't know what they are.
Jack: 哦防撞条
Jack: Oh, bumper strips.
Jake:怎怎怎么就撞成这样了
Jake: How did it get banged up like this?
Lucia:这不加还不知道撞成啥样了
Lucia: If we didn't add it, who knows how banged up it would be.
Tasha:釉中彩
Tasha: On-glaze colors.
Jake:还有釉中彩釉
Jake: There's on-glaze and in-glaze.
Jake:录着呢呵呵呵
Jake: We're recording, haha.
其他人：但是这是农夫山泉
Others: But this is Nongfu Spring.
Nicous: 啥呀我们能用一次性餐具之类的吗
Nicous: What, can we use disposable tableware and such?
Jake:不环保
Jake: Not eco-friendly.
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎几个
Katrina: How many cups did we break last time?
Katrina: 那明天人更多了
Katrina: There will be more people tomorrow.
Katrina: 够用吗
Katrina: Will it be enough?
Jake:那就买几个杯子
Jake: Then let's buy a few cups.
Katrina: 哦好的
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 买几个杯子
Tasha: Buy a few cups.
Tasha: 不是有一次性杯子吗
Tasha: Don't we have disposable cups?
Shure: 就是不符合我们的理念你懂吗
Shure: It's just that they don't match our concept, you know?
Jake:哈哈哈这个专业
Jake: Hahaha, this is professional.
Tasha: 搁搁那上楼
Tasha: Let's go upstairs.
Tasha: we need
Tasha: We need
Tasha: fruit
Tasha: 为你点灯为你
Tasha: Light a lamp for you, for you
Tasha: 为你点灯
Tasha: Light a lamp for you
Lucia:这能打开吗
Lucia: Can this be opened?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one
Shure: 这是三室的这个啊
Shure: This is a three-room one.
Shure: 四个四个
Shure: Four, four.
Jake:这多少钱啊
Jake: How much is this?
Choiszt: 这你要买要熟一点
Choiszt: If you want to buy this, it should be ripe.
Tasha: 我感觉这个这边不太好哎
Tasha: I feel like this side isn't very good.
Tasha: 我们来挑一个吗
Tasha: Should we pick one?
Choiszt: 23块一斤
Choiszt: 23 yuan per kilo.
Tasha: 我感觉这个
Tasha: I feel like this one
Jake:这个倒是性价比一般吧我感觉
Jake: This one has an average cost performance, I think.
Choiszt: 确实不如在新加坡买吧
Choiszt: It's indeed not as good as buying in Singapore.
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, true.
Jack: 新加坡榴莲应该很便宜
Jack: Durian in Singapore should be cheap.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:这些东西我觉得随便买到这
Jake: You can buy these things anywhere here.
Jake:我觉得不划算
Jake: I think it's not worth it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jack: 19块919块9新
Jack: 19.9 yuan, 19.9 yuan new.
Jack: 19块9新哈哈
Jack: 19.9 yuan new, haha.
Lucia:这么点吗
Lucia: Is it that little?
Jack: 打二折
Jack: 80% off.
其他人：这其实是
Others: This actually is
Lucia:OK我就说这个
Lucia: OK, I was talking about this.
Lucia:不会吧差那么远
Lucia: No way, such a big difference.
Lucia:那再来一盒吧哈哈
Lucia: Then let's get another box, haha.
Jake:但差不多也长这样
Jake: But it looks about the same.
Jake:我也吃不出来奥甘里克
Jake: I can't taste the difference.
Jake:我也吃不出来这些东西
Jake: I can't tell these things apart.
Lucia:真的有吓到我
Lucia: It really scared me.
Lucia:没想到啊
Lucia: I didn't expect that.
Lucia:我以为是在新加坡的价格
Lucia: I thought it was the price in Singapore.
Lucia:折成人民币也是9块9呢
Lucia: Converted to RMB, it's still 9.9.
Tasha: 买个这个吧
Tasha: Let's buy this.
Jake:这瓜真方
Jake: This melon is really square.
Tasha: 他这个是按491千克算的
Tasha: It's calculated at 491 kilograms.
Jake:哎这盒干嘛的
Jake: Hey, what's this box for?
Jake:西瓜西瓜要吗
Jake: Watermelon, watermelon, do you want it?
Tasha: 西瓜不要
Tasha: No watermelon.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:您还需要什么
Jake: Do you need anything else?
Tasha: 我们不是计划采购榴莲了吗
Tasha: Weren't we planning to buy durians?
Jake:鸡蛋
Jake: Eggs.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Tasha:假的有
Tasha: There are fake ones.
Jake:真的有吗
Jake: Are there real ones?
Tasha: 私人私人采购
Tasha: Private, private purchase.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Tasha:算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Jake:我都不记得表上写的什么
Jake: I don't even remember what's written on the list.
Jake:回头找j人对一对
Jake: We'll check with someone later.
Jake:我们p人就不管这些事了
Jake: We don't handle these things.
Jake:你这j还是p啊
Jake: Are you J or P?
Jack: j吧
Jack: J, I guess.
Jake:你忘了可还行
Jake: How can you forget that?
Jake:那看来是个p
Jake: Then it seems you're P.
Tasha: 那就是
Tasha: That's right.
Jake:哈哈哈看来是个p
Jake: Haha, it seems you're P.
Lucia:不知道哈哈
Lucia: I don't know, haha.
Jake:那是p了
Jake: Then it's P.
Jake:那真p了
Jake: Then it really is P.
Jack: 我是变过
Jack: I've changed.
Jack: 我是变过啊
Jack: I've changed, yeah.
Tasha: 哎怎么少了一批人啊
Tasha: Hey, why are we missing a batch of people?
Jake:哦哦哦在中间里面
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, they're in the middle.
Jake:咋地
Jake: What's up?
Tasha: 啊好累啊
Tasha: Ah, I'm so tired.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Katrina: 你要买什么
Katrina: What do you want to buy?
Tasha: 我没有要买
Tasha: I'm not going to buy it.
Tasha:我没有要买
Tasha: 我只是觉得这个虾怎么这么大
Tasha: I just think this shrimp is so big.
Tasha: 哈哈哈好些才20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha, some are only 20. Hahaha.
Katrina: 杨老板直接拿一袋
Katrina: Jake directly took a bag.
Choiszt: 这看着不是很新鲜
Choiszt: This doesn't look very fresh.
Jack: 但不知道他这这个
Jack: But I don't know about this.
Katrina: 今天晚上吃什么
Katrina: What are we having for dinner tonight?
Tasha: 为你点灯
Tasha: Light a lamp for you.
Tasha: it's okay it's okay
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: it's okay
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: da da da da da da
Tasha: Da da da da da da.
Shure: 走走走
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
阿姨：还有吗
Auntie: Is there more?
Choiszt: 提前预备着
Choiszt: Prepare in advance.
Alice:嗯没了
Alice: Hmm, no more.
Tasha: yes okay
Tasha: Yes, okay.
Tasha: it's okay it's okay
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 哒哒哒哒哒
Tasha: Da da da da da.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Katrina: 这是拿来当早饭还是当明天的糕点
Katrina: Is this for breakfast or tomorrow's snack?
Jake:这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Choiszt: 晚上的糕点
Choiszt: Tonight's snack.
Jake:晚上晚上的糕点
Jake: Tonight, tonight's snack.
Jake:没有晚上我们要做糕点了
Jake: No, tonight we're making snacks.
Jake:晚上我们要做很多很多很多很多糕点
Jake: Tonight we're going to make lots and lots and lots of snacks.
Tasha: 靠竟然是巧克力
Tasha: Wow, it's actually chocolate.
Jack: 给你们摇来了我们的金主啊
Jack: I've brought our sponsor for you all.
Tasha: 什么好吃
Tasha: What's delicious?
Tasha: 牛排方便面
Tasha: Steak instant noodles.
Tasha: 没有吃到
Tasha: Didn't get to eat.
Jake:牛排方便面怎么样
Jake: How about steak instant noodles?
Jake:主厨说要吃麦当劳
Jake: The chef said to eat McDonald's.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:主厨决定要吃麦当劳
Jake: The chef decided to eat McDonald's.
Tasha: 哈谁
Tasha: Huh, who?
Jake:我们的主厨主厨我们的主厨
Jake: Our chef, our chef, our chef.
Tasha: 你吗
Tasha: Is it you?
Tasha: 他也要吃麦当劳啊
Tasha: He wants to eat McDonald's too?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 对太好了
Tasha: Yes, that's great!
Jake:他也吃麦当劳
Jake: He also eats McDonald's.
Nicous: 是谁提的麦当劳啊
Nicous: Who brought up McDonald's?
Tasha: 啊呃麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Ah, uh, McDonald's burger.
Jake:对就是他
Jake: Yes, it was him.
Tasha: 就是他昨天一直在唱麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: It was him singing about McDonald's burgers all day yesterday.
Jake:然后告诉我一晚上150
Jake: Then he told me it's 150 a night.
Jake:我靠我这
Jake: Gosh, I...
Jake:哈哈哈建立了一些不可磨灭的联系
Jake: Haha, we've formed some unbreakable bonds.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jack: 哈哈可真好吃
Jack: Haha, it's really tasty.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Jack: 回去回去要买一个放我宿舍
Jack: When we go back, I need to buy one and put it in my dorm.
Tasha: 没吃到
Tasha: Didn't get to eat it.
Jack: 现在买我还得拎回去
Jack: If I buy it now, I have to carry it back.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Tasha: 到底啥味啊
Tasha: What's it taste like?
Jake:就是你
Jake: It's you...
Jake:你看中的品种不在乎这个价钱
Jake: The kind you like, the price doesn't matter.
Tasha:怎么我们这么大一群人
Tasha: How come such a big group of us...
Tasha:就一辆购物车都没有呢
Tasha: ...don't even have a shopping cart?
Tasha: 要买一瓶鲜牛奶
Tasha: Need to buy a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia:曾经我们有一辆购物车
Lucia: We used to have a shopping cart.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:车丢了我们车丢了
Jake: The cart is gone, our cart is gone.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡耶吼
Tasha: McDonald's burger, yay!
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Tasha:麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Shure: 他这没有龙舌兰
Shure: They don't have tequila here.
Tasha:嗨
Tasha: Hi
Tasha: 我想吃面
Tasha: I want some noodles.
Jake:那你买
Jake: Then go buy some.
Tasha: 啊我只想尝尝
Tasha: Ah, I just want to try it.
Jake:那你去吃
Jake: Then go eat it.
Katrina: 白兰地是什么酒
Katrina: What kind of alcohol is brandy?
Tasha: 什么时候煮好呀
Tasha: When will it be ready?
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 嗯我不着急
Tasha: Hmm, I'm not in a hurry.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thank you.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 哎好意
Tasha: Ah, good intentions.
Jake:好吃吗
Jake: Is it good?
Tasha: 好吃
Tasha: It's good.
Jake:好吃
Jake: It's good.
Jake:问问一楼是不是
Jake: Ask if it's on the first floor.
Tasha: 麦当劳
Tasha: McDonald's.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Jake:旺仔牛奶要几瓶
Jake: How many bottles of Wangzai milk do you need?
Tasha: 够了
Tasha: That's enough.
Tasha:灯还亮吗
Tasha: Are the lights still on?
Jake:亮着
Jake: They're on.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 哎如果今天晚上吃的话就要两瓶
Tasha: Ah, if we eat tonight, we need two bottles.
Tasha: 明天如果还做的话还要两瓶
Tasha: If we cook tomorrow, we need two more bottles.
Jake:那再来两瓶
Jake: Then get two more bottles.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 今天晚上大家要一起吃是吗
Tasha: Everyone's eating together tonight, right?
Jake:吃
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:好贵啊 5块8一瓶
Tasha: So expensive, 5.8 yuan per bottle.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 没看错吧
Tasha: Did I see that right?
Jake:啊为什么
Jake: Ah, why?
Tasha:哦这两个是一样大的
Tasha: Oh, these two are the same size.
Tasha: 你来算这两个哪个划算
Tasha: Can you figure out which one is more cost-effective?
Jake:这个不一样的
Jake: These are different.
Jake:这这这净含量不一样哎
Jake: The net content is different.
Jake:对吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 你算呀
Tasha: Just calculate it.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Jake:你你你给你能给我一个这东西我来算
Jake: Can you give me one of these so I can calculate?
Tasha:12块钱这个就是3块钱一罐
Tasha: This one is 12 yuan, so it's 3 yuan per can.
Jake:这多少升啊
Jake: How many liters is this?
Tasha:145
Tasha: 145
Jake:你咋看出来的
Jake: How did you figure that out?
Tasha:这写着呢啊
Tasha: It's written here.
Jake:哦哦哦对不起
Jake: Oh, oh, sorry.
Jake:那我们来算一算
Jake: Let's calculate it.
Tasha: 我靠你不要这么依赖
Tasha: Oh my god, don't be so dependent.
Jake:那得依赖100多少
Jake: I have to depend on you. How much is 100?
Tasha: 145*4
Tasha: 145 times 4.
Jake:145*4*4总共580升
Jake: 145 times 4 times 4, total is 580 liters.
Jake:11块12块钱
Jake: 11 yuan, 12 yuan.
Jake:多少
Jake: How much?
Jake:哈哈 540升是吧
Jake: Haha, it's 540 liters, right?
Jake:然后这个是
Jake: And this one is...
Tasha:5.8
Tasha: 5.8
Jake:245 是4490是吧
Jake: 245 times 4 equals 490, right?
Jake:490 哦
Jake: 490, oh.
Tasha: 为什么是490
Tasha: Why is it 490?
Jake:因为乘了两个
Jake: Because we multiplied by two.
Tasha: 可是这不是单罐吗
Tasha: But this is just one can.
Jake:5.8/245
Jake: 5.8 divided by 245.
Tasha: 245哪个便宜
Tasha: Which one is cheaper, 245?
Jake:他便宜
Jake: This one is cheaper.
Tasha: 他便宜
Tasha: This one is cheaper.
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 那就拿4个这个就行了
Tasha: Then just take four of these.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:走
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 把那把那两个抛弃掉哎呀
Tasha: Throw those two away, oh my.
Jake:哎哎呀哎呀哎呀对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Oh, oh my, oh my, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Tasha: 不是对不起就可以弥补的
Tasha: Sorry isn't enough to make up for it.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: Then what should we do?
Tasha: 呵呵没想好呢
Tasha: Haha, I haven't thought about it yet.
Tasha: 经过我们严密严整的计算
Tasha: After our careful and precise calculation...
Jake:加餐呢
Jake: Extra meal?
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yes, this one.
Jake:稍微便宜
Jake: It's a bit cheaper.
Jake:能便宜个一毛半
Jake: It can be cheaper by fifteen cents.
Shure: 一毛半新币
Shure: Fifteen cents in new currency?
Tasha: 一毛半人民币
Tasha: Fifteen cents in RMB.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈为了这一毛半然后在这纠结
Choiszt: Hahaha, arguing over fifteen cents.
Choiszt: 然后买了好多额外的
Choiszt: And then buying a lot of extras.
Tasha: 抠抠搜搜花了很多
Tasha: Pinching pennies but spending a lot.
Nicous: 这个和这个放在一起我有点于心不忍
Nicous: Putting this and that together makes me feel uneasy.
Tasha: 为什么哦
Tasha: Why?
Nicous: 那搁那车
Nicous: That car.
Shure: 都是meta付
Shure: It's all about Meta payments.
Shure: 他应该已经学完了
Shure: He should have finished learning by now.
Shure: 不是吗
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们开发票开什么
Shure: Should we issue the invoice?
Shure: 开什么脸书有限公司是吧
Shure: Should we invoice it to Facebook Ltd?
Tasha: 脸书
Tasha: Facebook.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Shure: 我们开发票的话应该开
Shure: If we are issuing invoices, it should be...
Tasha: 当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McMcMcDonald's burger.
Tasha: 这可以这可以结账
Tasha: This can be billed.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McMcMcDonald's burger.
Lucia:说到这个既然快递都到的差不多了
Lucia: Speaking of which, since most of the packages have arrived...
Lucia:可以报销一下吗
Lucia: Can we get reimbursed?
Jake:可可以啊
Jake: Yes, sure.
Jake:可以发账单嘛
Jake: You can send the bill.
Jack: 所以我好奇那这的钱谁出
Jack: So I'm curious, who's paying for this?
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 我要弄吗
Tasha: Should I do it?
Tasha: 哎都大家都要弄Excel是吗
Tasha: Hey, everyone needs to use Excel, right?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 是不是他他弄一个然后共享
Shure: Shouldn't he make one and share it?
Shure: 咱们贴就行
Shure: Then we just paste it.
Lucia:哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Yeah, okay.
Tasha: 哎呦sorry
Tasha: Oh sorry.
Lucia:哦sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh sorry, hahaha.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:你懂吗你懂吗你懂我吗你懂吗
Jake: Do you understand? Do you understand me?
其他人：你可能还不太懂哈哈
Others: Maybe you don't quite get it, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:可能下个月让你懂一懂
Jake: Maybe next month you'll get it.
Lucia:我们要不要来一盒
Lucia: Should we get a box?
Lucia:请嘉宾喝
Lucia: To treat the guest?
Shure: 60新币啊哈哈哈 60新
Shure: 60 SGD, hahaha. 60 SGD.
Lucia: 但是但是他们家茶真的很好
Lucia: But their tea is really good.
Lucia:这应该是一个北京的老字号好像
Lucia: It seems to be a long-established brand in Beijing.
Jake:没有灯
Jake: There's no light.
Jack: 回到中国什么东西一除五就感觉没有那么贵
Jack: When you convert everything to Chinese yuan, it doesn't seem as expensive.
Jake:那确实那确实
Jake: That's true, that's true.
Shure: 那谁的线掉了
Shure: Whose cable fell?
Lucia:他再多待几天回新加坡就该乘5了
Lucia: If he stays a few more days, it'll be back to SGD prices.
Lucia:是我的是我的
Lucia: It's mine, it's mine.
Shure: 你的生命线哈哈哈
Shure: Your lifeline, hahaha.
Shure: 生命线姐
Shure: Lifeline girl.
Lucia:OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Tasha:结账吧
Tasha: Let's pay.
Lucia:我给眼镜续个命哈
Lucia: Let me fix my glasses.
Lucia:他现在没灭吧
Lucia: It's not out yet, right?
Jake:没灭
Jake: It's not out.
Lucia:那就行
Lucia: That's good.
Jake:给他拍一个照
Jake: Take a picture of it.
Lucia:83特别满
Lucia: 83 is really full.
Shure: 所有的酒都没有
Shure: There's no more alcohol.
Jake:所有酒都没有
Jake: There's no alcohol.
Jake:那就买吧
Jake: Then just buy it.
Jake:你要不现在就买吧
Jake: Why don't you just buy it now?
Tasha: 呃呃呃呃呃呃
Tasha: Uh uh uh uh uh uh
Lucia:哎这里面还有一
Lucia: Hey, there's still a
Lucia:个充电宝
Lucia: power bank in here
Tasha:it's me
Tasha: It's me
Lucia:好的
Lucia: Okay
Jake:你要不也插上生命线
Jake: Why don't you also plug in the lifeline?
Tasha:哎那个人招手让我们过去呢
Tasha: Hey, that person is waving for us to go over
Lucia:要插吗我帮你找地方扔
Lucia: Do you want to plug it in? I can help you find a place to throw it
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I
Lucia:一会再插
Lucia: Plug it in later
Jake:他一直不给我
Jake: He never gives it to me
Jake:就是他自
Jake: It's just he himself
Jake:己人不是
Jake: isn't...
Tasha: 哎呀我不好意思让你帮我拿
Tasha: Oh, I feel embarrassed asking you to hold it for me
Shure: 那也行吧
Shure: That's fine, I guess
Jack: 没事没事
Jack: It's okay, it's okay
Tasha: 麦麦麦哎
Tasha: Mai mai mai hey
Tasha: 我的宝呢
Tasha: Where's my treasure?
Lucia:吓死了我刚还以为这根线找不到了呢
Lucia: It scared me, I thought I couldn't find this cable
Tasha: 找不到了要赔多少钱
Tasha: How much would it cost if it's lost?
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know
Lucia:没有考虑过这种问题
Lucia: I've never considered that
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mai mai McDonald's burger
Jake:就一些很难想的问题我们就不想了
Jake: We just don't think about those tough questions
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mai mai McDonald's burger
Tasha: 你好可以给我个手撕袋吗
Tasha: Hi, can I get a hand-torn bag?
Tasha: 好的谢谢你
Tasha: Okay, thank you
Tasha:麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mai mai McDonald's burger
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Nicous: 有没有我的水
Nicous: Is my water there?
Jake:你给多少钱都得鞭
Jake: No matter how much you pay, you have to whip
Jack: 我忘了无心之过哎
Jack: I forgot, it was unintentional
Jake:啊已经碎了
Jake: Ah, it's already broken
Lucia:啊没有没有
Lucia: Ah, no, no
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Jack: 哔哩哔哩干杯
Jack: Bilibili cheers
Lucia:虽然这个语序完全错乱
Lucia: Although the word order is completely messed up
Lucia:但好像能看懂呢
Lucia: But it seems like we can understand it.
Lucia:什么杯子
Lucia: What kind of cup?
Shure: 不是这两个拿
Shure: Not these two, take them.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye.
Jake:关了吧
Jake: Turn it off.
Jake:哎上车就关
Jake: Yeah, turn it off when you get in the car.
Jake:好上车关好
Jake: Okay, get in the car and turn it off properly.
Tasha: stale hour for
Tasha: no
Jake:style
Jake: style
Jake:powerful什么东西
Jake: What's powerful?
Tasha: no 哈哈哈
Tasha: no hahaha
Jake:no
Jake: no
Tasha:还是我们4个
Tasha: Still just the four of us.
Lucia:中文语式打乱并不影响阅读
Lucia: The Chinese syntax being messed up doesn't affect readability.
Lucia:大概能看懂是什么意思吧
Lucia: You can roughly understand what it means, right?
Jake:购物时购买1二81元元一
Jake: When shopping, buy something for 1281 yuan.
Jake:我靠满一二8元
Jake: Whoa, spend over 128 yuan.
Lucia:满12 8元一分钱购洗衣凝珠
Lucia: Spend 128 yuan and get laundry pods for a penny.
Jake:一分钱够洗衣凝珠
Jake: Spend a penny and get laundry pods.
Tasha: 为什么我们不买
Tasha: Why didn't we buy it?
Tasha: 为什么不买
Lucia:他送了一个
Lucia: He gave us one.
Jake:他是他是
Jake: He did, he did.
Jake:购物首付满821元
Jake: First payment when shopping over 821 yuan.
Jake:就这个是对的
Jake: This one is correct.
Lucia: 哈哈满128元
Lucia: Haha, over 128 yuan.
Tasha:他要从这边开始看
Tasha: He should start reading from this side.
Jake:那12828 哈哈哈
Jake: Then 128, 28 haha.
Tasha: 为什么不分开买两个也128呢
Tasha: Why don't we split it into two purchases of 128 each?
Lucia:哎有道理
Lucia: Hey, that makes sense.
Lucia:但反正
Lucia: But anyway,
Lucia:他当时确实给咱送了一盒洗衣凝珠
Lucia: He did give us a box of laundry pods at that time.
Tasha: 应该送两盒
Tasha: He should give us two boxes.
Lucia:对我们应该结完128就
Lucia: Yeah, we should finish the 128 and then...
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:好走吧这个就放那吧
Jake: Okay, let's go, just leave this here.
Lucia:你看这个就是从左往右阅读
Lucia: Look, this one is read from left to right.
Tasha: 那为什么我们不在多点会员上面免费
Tasha: Then why don't we get more free stuff with the membership?
Tasha: 满150元就可以免费送到家了
Tasha: Spend over 150 yuan and get free delivery to your home.
Jake:字体为什么能做成这个样子
Jake: Why is the font like this?
Jake:他为了省纸是吧
Jake: Is he doing this to save paper?
Lucia:那那个满字为什么那么大
Lucia: Then why is that "full" character so big?
Jake:满可能他省不了太挤了
Jake: Maybe he couldn't save space with "full", it's too crowded.
Tasha: 晨会宣讲套
Tasha: Morning meeting kit.
Jake:养乐多
Jake: Yakult.
Tasha: 那不是养乐多
Tasha: That's not Yakult.
Tasha: 那是UEC
Tasha: That's UEC.
Jake:哦不一样
Jake: Oh, it's different.
Tasha: 假的
Tasha: It's fake.
Jake:呵呵呵山寨
Jake: Haha, a knockoff.
Jake:我打个车
Jake: I'll call a cab.
Tasha: 好看你要不要买
Tasha: It looks nice, do you want to buy it?
Tasha: 你这也是十十个色
Tasha: This one also comes in ten colors.
Jake:呵呵确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Lucia:这这是毛的吧
Lucia: This, is this wool?
Lucia:不是不是是是那普通的夏天的衣服
Lucia: No, no, it's just a regular summer outfit.
Tasha: 涤纶
Tasha: Polyester.
Lucia:没摸出来但应该不是棉不像纯棉
Lucia: I can't tell by touch, but it doesn't seem like cotton, not pure cotton.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 天呐噜
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Lucia:消失
Lucia: Disappear.
Jack: 居然无条件信任
Jack: Unconditional trust, huh?
Tasha: 啊哎呀
Tasha: Ah, oh no.
Jack: 那建议把我去首都的车车车费也报了
Jack: Then I suggest reimbursing my travel expenses to the capital too.
Jake:对这个
Jake: Yes, that...
Jake:总之就是算个总账拿个清单
Jake: In short, just calculate the total and get a list.
Jack: 哎
Jack: Hey.
Jack: 那你周二从从北京飞到新加坡上海
Jack: So, on Tuesday, you fly from Beijing to Singapore, Shanghai.
Jake:没想到呢
Jake: Didn't expect that.
Jake:就是没想到这层了对对对
Jake: Just didn't think this through, yeah, yeah.
Jack: 这次先先过完明天
Jack: Let's just get through tomorrow first.
Jake:后天再想这一层
Jake: We'll think about it the day after tomorrow.
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Lucia:没事他可以到了机场
Lucia: It's fine, he can get to the airport.
Lucia:然后随机选择一个目的地
Lucia: Then randomly choose a destination.
Jake:对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake:先到机场
Jake: First to the airport.
Jack: 是给航空公司捐钱的
Jack: It's like donating to the airline.
Jake:那不是
Jake: No, that's not it.
Jack: 你当天晚上很贵的
Jack: You were really expensive that night.
Jake:我我省钱啊
Jake: I was saving money.
Jake:你不知道啊
Jake: You didn't know?
Jake:没跟你讲过
Jake: I never told you?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈你错过了很精彩的故事
Lucia: Hahaha, you missed a really great story.
Jake:赶不上飞机
Jake: I missed the flight.
Jake:我通常我提前买赶不上飞机
Jake: Usually, I buy tickets early and still miss the flight.
Jake:就坐不上飞机
Jake: I just can't get on the plane.
Jake:然后要退票或者不给退的话也很麻烦
Jake: Then I have to refund the ticket, or if they don't refund, it's a big hassle.
Jake:所以就比较浪费钱
Jake: So it ends up wasting money.
Jack: 那你为什么不提前买好
Jack: Why don't you just buy it early?
Jake:就是提前买好的
Jake: I do buy it early.
Jack: 提前买好一个你能赶上的飞
Jack: Buy it early for a flight you can make.
Jake:那很难
Jake: That's hard.
Jack: 为什么
Jack: Why?
Jack: 哈这有点抽象
Jack: Haha, that's a bit abstract.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia:你看所有人听到都觉得不可思议
Lucia: Look, everyone who hears it thinks it's unbelievable.
Jack: 这有点抽象
Jack: That's a bit abstract.
Jack: 我操
Jack: Damn.
Jack: 这有点抽象
Jack: That's a bit abstract.
Jack: 这那很难受没想到
Jack: That's really hard to deal with, didn't expect that.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 他永远提前买好赶不上车
Tasha: He always buys the ticket early and still misses the bus.
Tasha: 这是很让人感觉很奇怪的事情
Tasha: It's really a strange thing.
Jake:哎呀到了到了到了到了
Jake: Oh, it's here, it's here, it's here.
Tasha: 他就是那种去电影院哎
Tasha: He's the type that goes to the cinema, hey.
Tasha: 下一场最近的时候是什么时候呀
Tasha: When's the next showtime?
Tasha: 然后他就直接买下一场开始看
Tasha: Then he just buys the next one and starts watching.
Lucia:这个我也会不过
Lucia: I do that too, but...
Lucia:不过我每我我去电影院
Jake:这个无所谓这个无所谓
Jake: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Lucia:每次都是先到那再看看哪一场
Lucia: I always get there first and then see which showtime.
Jack: 电影票的价钱是一样的
Jack: Movie ticket prices are the same.
Lucia:要不然我赶不到
Lucia: Otherwise, I can't make it.
Jack: 机票会贵很多的
Jack: Plane tickets are much more expensive.
Jake:也也没有贵很多的
Jake: Not really that much more expensive.
Jake:我发现
Jake: I found out...
Jack: 哎刘帅现在开的车是从哪
Jack: Hey, where is the car Choiszt is driving from?
Jack: 还是租的车
Jack: It's still a rented car.
Jake:8841啊这个
Jake: 8841, this one.
Lucia:我只要提前买电影票
Lucia: I just need to buy movie tickets in advance.
Lucia:就无论我提前多久
Lucia: No matter how early I buy them,
Lucia:我最后都会错过片头
Lucia: I always end up missing the beginning of the movie.
Tasha: 天
Tasha: Oh my.
Lucia:哈哈哈是不是也很匪夷所思
Lucia: Hahaha, isn't it unbelievable?
Jake:哈哈请请请
Jake: Haha, please, please.
Tasha: 啊这就到了
Tasha: Oh, we're here already.
Lucia:谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Jake:关
Jake: Close it.
Jake:可以我们不知道
Jake: Maybe we didn't know.
Lucia:今天这也不是很远
Lucia: Today, it's not that far.
Lucia:但我竟然真的有点晕车
Lucia: But I'm actually feeling a bit car sick.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it at that.
Lucia:啊上车是不是要关这个
Lucia: Oh, do we need to close this when we get in the car?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:他经常会提示我minor data quality issues detected
Lucia: It often prompts me with "minor data quality issues detected".
Jake:这个没有办法
Jake: There's no way around it.
Jake:因为没有办法
Jake: Because there's no way around it.
Jake:禁止左转哈哈哈
Jake: No left turn, hahaha.
Tasha:那我们要去哪里
Tasha: Then where are we going?
Lucia:没有他说咖啡店
Lucia: Didn't he say the coffee shop?
Jake:跳过跳过
Jake: Skip it, skip it.
Jake:这里跳过这里
Jake: Skip this part here.
Lucia:我现在真的有点PTSD
Lucia: I'm really getting a bit of PTSD right now.
Tasha: 有
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 有有有
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:谢云茹他这边有这个修
Jake: Xie Yunru over here has this repair thing.
Jake:叫什么回收旧的电器
Jake: What's it called, recycling old appliances?
Tasha: 哈哈哈为什么要喊他
Tasha: Hahaha, why call him?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:为什么要喊他
Tasha: Why call him?
Tasha: 我们有
Tasha: We have it.
Jake:因为他明天把琴带过来了
Jake: Because he's bringing the piano tomorrow.
Tasha: 他把琴带过来
Tasha: He's bringing the piano?
Lucia:然后我们说他怎么拿回去
Lucia: Then we asked him how he'll take it back.
Lucia:他说当二手直接在这卖了
Lucia: He said he'd sell it as secondhand right here.
Lucia:随意哈哈哈哈sorry
Lucia: Whatever, hahahaha, sorry.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia:哈哈对不起我现在真的有点ptst
Lucia: Hahaha, sorry, I'm really getting a bit of PTSD now.
Lucia:因为那个好近然后
Lucia: Because it's so close and...
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:但是一般恶犬那种叫的人不会
Jake: But usually, those barking dogs won't...
Lucia:内有恶犬
Lucia: Beware of dog.
Jake:不会咬你那小狗
Jake: They won't bite you, that little dog.
Lucia:内有恶犬
Lucia: Beware of dog.
Jake:它就它呆它包里
Jake: It just stays in its bag.
Lucia:对那个小狗只是个无心之师
Lucia: Yeah, that little dog is just an innocent teacher.
Jake:密码多少
Jake: What's the password?
Jake:哈哈哈玩球
Jake: Hahaha, play ball.
Lucia:要我帮你拿一个吗
Lucia: Want me to get one for you?
Jake:不哎可以你要不拿这个吧
Jake: No, wait, you can take this one.
Lucia:都行都行
Lucia: Either way is fine.
Jake:那那拆一个
Jake: Then open one.
Lucia:那我拆了
Lucia: I'll open it then.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我们三个分了吧要不
Jake: Why don't we split it among the three of us?
Lucia:哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha, sounds good, sounds good.
Tasha:我们三个人的瓜分史还少吗
Tasha: Haven't we divided stuff among the three of us enough times?
Jake:哈哈哈哈芒果还剩一个
Jake: Hahaha, there's only one mango left.
Lucia:芒果还剩一个都不够
Lucia: One mango isn't enough.
Lucia:咱仨瓜分的哈哈
Lucia: We'll split it among the three of us, haha.
Lucia:哎你今天转化的那个呢
Lucia: Hey, what about the one you converted today?
Jake:咱没称因为我全给转化了
Jake: We didn't weigh it because I converted it all.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈转化到肚子里了是吗
Lucia: Haha, converted it into your stomach, right?
Jake:全被我转化了
Jake: I converted it all.
Lucia:行
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:维他维他他买了吗
Jake: Did he buy Vita?
Lucia:好像没有
Lucia: I don't think so.
Jake:白玉田蓝莓草莓
Jake: What about white jade, blueberries, and strawberries?
Lucia:也没看着
Lucia: Didn't see those either.
Lucia:百利甜也没看着
Lucia: Didn't see Baileys either.
Jake:这这什么字啊
Jake: What's this word?
Jake:草莓后面青提
Jake: After strawberries, green grapes.
Tasha: 青提
Tasha: Green grapes.
Jake:榴莲
Jake: Durian.
Lucia:看成定投了
Lucia: I read it as "regular investment."
Tasha: 什么头
Tasha: What investment?
Lucia:定投
Lucia: Regular investment.
Lucia:是一个金融术语
Lucia: It's a financial term.
Jake:好吧定投
Jake: Oh, regular investment.
Jake:我懂了哈哈
Jake: Got it, haha.
Lucia:哈哈哈打扰了
Lucia: Haha, sorry.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Alice:有没有觉得非常干净
Alice: Doesn't it look super clean?
Tasha: 哈哈不认识这个家了
Tasha: Haha, I don't recognize this place anymore.
Alice:但是一摆又又又凌乱了
Alice: But once you start arranging things, it gets messy again.
Tasha: 我天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Alice:有没有觉得这个家有什么区别
Alice: Do you feel any difference in this house?
Jake:有有有请请请
Jake: Yes, yes, please, please.
Jake:您嗑瓜子请呵呵
Jake: Please have some sunflower seeds, hehe.
Lucia:特别有区别
Lucia: There's a big difference.
Lucia:请请请您吃
Lucia: Please, please, have some.
Alice:我不吃巧克力
Alice: I don't eat chocolate.
Lucia:喝喝喝来来来杯茶
Lucia: Drink, drink, have some tea.
Alice:谢谢哈哈哈哈
Alice: Thanks, hahaha.
Jack: 一整个公众号的信息连续性更好
Jack: An entire public account's information is more consistent.
Jack: 就你直接把10个QQ拼起来就
Jack: You can just put together 10 QQs and...
Alice:现在只有就剩刷的东西没有弄了
Alice: Now we only have the brushing left to do.
Jake:好我们来刷
Jake: Okay, let's brush.
Alice:还有楼上的桌子什么也擦了
Alice: And also wipe the tables upstairs.
Alice:然后也只剩刷了
Alice: Then it's just the brushing left.
Nicous: 还得自己
Nicous: We still need to do it ourselves.
Jake:我们开摄像头
Jake: Let's turn on the camera.
Jack: 开摄像头啊
Jack: Turn on the camera?
Jake:大家先休息一下
Jake: Everyone, take a break first.
Jake:不要工作
Jake: Don't work.
其他人：这个去哪了啊啊
Others: Where did this go, ah?
Jake:这个不要了
Jake: We don't need this.
Jake:这个放后面了
Jake: Put this in the back.
Tasha:那这个眼镜就关掉了啊
Tasha: Then I'll turn off these glasses.
Jake:呃关关关
Jake: Uh, turn them off, turn them off.
Jake:倒一批
Jake: Pour a batch.